Let's translate various film terminology and best practices
into those applicable to game development.
On the left is a list of various actors, components,
and things Unreal Engine includes.
It's important to note that many of the items can be added to
and manipulated within a sequence.
Control Rig, for an example, is predominantly
animated through Sequencer.
On the right are various terminologies
we use when working with sequences.
Scene Assemblies are the complete encapsulated collection
of actors, animations, and logic nested within a sequence.
Performance Takes is a feature that
allows you to record animation from motion capture
performances or input devices using an iterative workflow
to automatically record the motion to a sequence.
This tool is extremely useful time saver
in capturing multiple variations of a single shot
and can be reviewed on the fly.
Takes can be swapped directly within a sequence
via the shot properties from the dropdown menu.
Sets, layout, staging, these all
refer to the assembly of our actors in our scene
or within our sequence via spawnables or swappables
that essentially create the final look of our scene.
Level Sequenced with Shots refers
to our graduated or parent sequences
within nested sequences or shots.
It's important to note that shots are not
a specific actor type.
In fact, subtracts, shots, nested sequences,
and parent tracks are all the same actor type.
They're all sequences.
It's how you use those sequences that really
determines its functionality.
On the left are various stages or assemblies
when working with traditional film practices.
On the right, we've translated those terminologies
into terminology commonly used with Unreal Engine,
specifically when working with sequences.
I won't cover each line, but I do
encourage you to pause the video
and read through the slide to get more in-depth information
and understanding how we translate film terminology
that we use in Unreal.